She is not withholding sex from you.
I am a divorced woman. I will tell you why the sex has stopped
and why the dead bedroom has begun.
You remind her too much of her small children.
All day long she's at home,
can barely take a shower, brush her teeth
or take a shit in peace without somebody screaming and crying.
And you know what's interrupting her?
A child having a fucking tantrum
because his Cheerios fell on the floor
or he can't find his nerf gun
or he put his shirt on inside out
and he doesn't understand how to fix it.
The world is gonna end right now.
And so this kid is having a fucking shit fit,
and as a loving mother, she's happy to be there and support him.
But when your ugly, smelly,
disgusting ass comes home from work
and does the exact same shit
that the four year old little boy was doing all day.
Sir, we don't find small children sexually attractive,
so we're not gonna find you sexually attractive either.
Your wife doesn't know how to say that,
cause she knows if she tries to say it,
your fucking little baby feelings are gonna get hurt,
you're gonna throw another fucking tantrum.
And now she's in even deeper shit
and even triply more fucking unattractive to you.
She doesn't have the nerve to tell you,
and I will. You remind her too much of her children
and that's why the sex Has stopped